AMANDA GORMAN: No matter who
you are, learning about poetry
is a huge source of power.
You too can write words that
will set the world on fire.
We braved the
belly of the beast,
We've learned that quiet
isn't always peace.
And the norms and
notions of what
"just is," isn't always justice.
You're going to learn not
only how to be a great poet
but how to be a changemaker.
When I was first writing poems,
what made them so special to me
was that experience of having my
feelings articulated and named
on the page.
I could verbalize what
was going on in here
that people didn't know.
For there is always
light if only
we're brave enough
to see it, if only
we're brave enough to be it.
You should write at
least once every day.
You can write gibberish.
You can draw scarecrows.
Like, you can do whatever.
Just get your pen moving.
I'm going to be sharing
ugly drafts of my own poems
and show you what
it means to perform
in front of an audience.
Trying to be heard but these
words don't sound right.
Could I ever be
in the spotlight?
When I was little, I
had a speech impediment,
which made it very difficult
for me to speak up for myself.
A lot of my first few
poems were about what
it was like to be lonely,
because I might not
look or speak like the
students around me.
There's always another
story to write,
always another verse
waiting on the horizon.
We all can harness
the power of poetry
to become stronger
communicators,
better leaders, and also
more compassionate people.
I'm Amanda Gorman, and
this is MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I want to be the
teacher I never had.
[MUSIC PLAYING]